[Music]
please welcome lupe fiasco
you hope the moon heals but it never
does
that's cause you at war with love
[Music]
[Music]
these battles
love never let a wound ruin me
but i feel like bruins warning me
arrow hoes that never closed cupid on
the shooting spree feeling stupid cause
i know where they know you and me but
when you're trying to beat the odds up
and trying to keep your knots up and you
know that you should knock down
and let it go but the fear in the
unknown another lover's phone sends you
back into the zone we go with no time
hanks to bring you home
[Music]
until you
until you tell me
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't
[Music]
now you down on the ground screaming
medic the only thing that comes is the
post-traumatic stresses
with shields body armors and blessings
don't properly work that's why an
[Music]
i'm the only one that's trying to keep
[Music]
until you tell me yourself
[Music]
[Music]
and it's impossible to say
hope it heals but it never does
[Music]
[Music]
changed
[Music]
[Applause]
peace
[Music]
that was fantastic thank you that was
great thank you so much
that went very well
you've made me ask for featuring guys
sebastian